[Music]
The Bachelor has the entire process I
was talking about it for a couple weeks
but when I knew that I finally was
writing that I wanted to Segen I there
was no turning back
oh yeah I mean I have grown a lot I have
become much more patient I would say and
I feel like especially this time around
I have become much more confident and
just really comfortable in my own skin
and with who I am know so actually how
it all worked out is I knew that it
would be re because he was known style I
think Good Morning America and then that
day that he was announced I got the
final call saying you know we want you
come out to California so I knew at that
point it was gonna be re and not Peter
Oh oh my god I ate so much every night
the entire night for the guys in the
kitchen they have a caterer so they have
everything for a little hors d'oeuvres -
mac and cheese - chicken but I don't get
to go into the kitchen unfortunately so
I would have just a ton of chicken
nuggets and a ton of peanut butter
that's what got me through the entire
season filming you know we started I
probably got to the mansion around 7:30
I would say and I probably walked out
the next morning at around 8:30 or 9:00
but I had a lot of snack breaks
okay so we do get a packing list it is
very generic so it's like some jeans
some sweaters some shorts a couple
dresses but we have to pack everything
into only two suitcases and you're
potentially gone for two months and so
it's difficult I am the worst Packer in
the entire world and they over pack and
so I had a lot of stuff I do still have
all of the dresses from Rachel's so
actually not all of them I got I think
five or six of them and then the jewelry
I got one pair of earrings from Neil
Lane that I got to keep so yes I do
still have it all oh and the shoes I
think that I got the beautiful silver
shoes too which actually weirdly enough
I'll still put on sometimes at my
apartment they walk around in no God so
in my ex showed up in Peru that was
probably the biggest blindside I had had
up until you know the break-up I did not
see it coming I honestly thought when I
heard the knock on the door that it
would be either one of the producers or
Ari himself just coming over I did not
expect to see Ross on the other end it
wasn't a pleasant surprise though have
you guys spoken since that no not at all
I mean not talked to him since I
shouldn't he should have really came if
I'm being honest but I mean last season
in this season it's always a change when
you realize how exhausting it is and you
don't get a ton of sleep what are the
best surprises though is I think just
meeting all the girls last year and
really becoming close friends with a lot
of them and not only building the
friendship but knowing that those
friendships are gonna last a lifetime
the girls okay well so we're filming
most of the time I've never lived in a
sorority but I can only imagine that's
kind of what it's like is you know
you're just cooking meals together and
you're drinking coffee together in your
lane by the pool and you don't have your
phone you don't have TVs you don't have
music and so it's really just
interacting them building friendships
with these women and especially last
season we I think we're really lucky
with the group of girls that were all
together one of them I will say it's not
my best moment but I had a few cocktails
and I took a long nap behind a couch for
a while on one of the group dates behind
a couch it happens right behind a couch
in a fireplace and I was just sitting
there talking with I think Chelsea and
it was just so cozy you're just jerking
off to sleep and you know she's a mom so
she got a pillow put it under my head
covered me with a nice fur blanket I'm
actually kind of got a legit main TV
[Music]
quite honestly
everyone was portrayed as how they were
in the moment and how things were
playing along you know during that day
or that we you know the there was drama
with Krystal between some of the girls
but Krystal is a good person she was
kind she got along well with the girls
for the most part but there were moments
where people you know kind of get a
little stir-crazy and things happen but
everything that we all say and do is
real and it's organic and so I think
that was all captured as it really
happened no um I didn't think that Ari
was gonna end the engagement I knew that
he had been struggling with his feelings
and feeling guilty in how he sent Lauryn
home but I didn't see the break up that
day happening at all
I still keep in touch with a lot of the
girls actually from re-season yeah a lot
of the girls I mean and you'll see them
throughout they the girls that run after
the final rose with me I have stuck by
my side throughout the entire journey
and that will talk to Chelsea also talk
to Ashley some of the other girls too
oh man see this is the thing it's hard
with advice because iPhone is so
different but I mean for me when I went
through the breakup with Ari I wanted to
just go back to my normal life and just
still do me and so I went straight back
into work and I stayed busy and I was
always with my friends and family and I
think you know staying busy and still
doing me and doing my normal routine
helped but then also I am a journalist
and so that helped me really sift
through my thoughts my feelings where I
was that day by day and then I mean I
don't know if this girl can do this but
it helped watching my season back with
Ari and watching his relationship with
Lauren and the other women unfold to
kind of see where he was you know in his
relationship with me versus the others
no I honestly don't think I would change
anything I don't really regret anything
I feel like it really stayed true to who
I was and said what I wanted to say did
what I wanted her had to do in each
moment yeah I think I mean no I don't
think I would change anything I am open
to doing whatever is best for my
relationship and with my partner and as
much as I love Minnesota I don't feel
like I need to always stay there and so
it's really what my partner and I decide
you know whether if we end up in LA or a
different city that neither of us have
lived in before I'm cool with that too
I'm open to anything
[Music]
future advice any bachelor bachelorettes
would be always carry a snack on you
because the days are long and you never
know when you're gonna have a proper
meal mine was peanut butter I always
kept peanut butter on me and just make
sure you take time for yourself like
whether it's to journal or just sit and
think or just stand in your shower for
an extra 10 or 15 minutes like you'll
need that alone time because you're
constantly around people 24/7 and so
take time for yourself take care of your
body listen to yourself when you need it
the most I 1,000% believe in the journey
it worked last time around and it worked
this time around so much more and yeah
it works it works
it's a crazy unconventional worthwhile
journey but you can find love